we're going to start today with dyed
suddenly what does that mean someone
died suddenly has become the new code
for the covid vaccine is killing people
now this has all come to an extremely
stupid Crescendo because of what
happened with the collapse and cardiac
arrest of NFL football player Damar
Hamlin on the field uh during an NFL
game a little over a week ago and as you
know if you've been watching this
program because we've been we've been
following it I even got some voicemails
about it that I played for you the gist
of the story is that Demar Hamlin
collapsed not because he got hit in a
particular way
but because of the covet vaccine the
covet vaccine which by the way nobody
knew whether Demar Hamlin had actually
received at the time that people started
saying the vaccine is to blame and this
brings us to a bigger story that has
been building the died suddenly
conspiracy theory is the idea that
people who have received the covid-19
vaccine are either dying at an unusual
rate the story is always otherwise
healthy people are suddenly dying for
unexplained reasons that's one piece of
it or experiencing health effects of
different different kinds now there is a
lot that we could say about this and so
many different things there's even a
film called died suddenly which rehashes
a lot of these same debunked claims but
a lot of this has to do with some really
basic logical fallacies that I hope I've
done an okay job of educating people
about over the years on the show and it
also has to do with something called the
base rate bias so there's really two
things going on here first of all it's a
fundamental issue of correlation versus
causation we sometimes call this
post-hoc Ergo Proctor Hawk meaning
it happened afterwards therefore it
happened because of
or to put it another way
B happened after a therefore a must have
caused B
and uh when you zoom out you very
quickly see how faulty this sort of
thinking is so let's start tight and
then we'll zoom out let's start with
Demar Hamlin are there examples of
cardiac arrest during sporting events
among athletes yeah there are
um you know in in major sports Detroit
Lion Chuck Hughes had a fatal heart
attack on the field in 1971. that's the
only NFL player to die while playing
um Danish soccer player Christian
Erickson suffered Cardiac Arrest during
a tournament in 2021 Hockey Hall of
Famer Chris pronger's heart stopped when
he was hit in the chest by a hockey puck
NHL player J boomister or bowmeester I'm
not exactly sure on the pronunciation
collapsed on the bench after a cardiac
episode Mark Vivienne foe died during a
2003 semi-final match from an
undiagnosed heart condition that was a
soccer death all of these
um uh have not have not been claimed to
have anything to do with vaccines most
of them predate the covet vaccines so
the Demar Hamlin situation is not unique
but that's not really the big story
the big story is you have to understand
base rates when you test a vaccine as
was done by Pfizer and moderna before
the covet vaccines were fully released
to the public
um a lot of these uh studies clinical
trials had 40 000 adults for example 40
000 adults and so someone who wants to
think critically about this issue rather
than fear Monger or spread conspiracy
theories would say if you have a group
of adults if you take 18 plus 40 000
people distributed among ages how many
of them would you expect to die over a
three-month period aside from whether
you're testing anything and what I mean
by that is if you take a group of forty
thousand people
and you just follow them for three
months
you would expect some to die if their
ages are normally distributed and it's a
tough question to answer exactly for a
vaccine test group because it could
depend on particular choices that are
made for who's included or who's not
who's not included but there's something
called the crude death rate that's the
number of deaths per thousand people a
year overall for in the U.S the crude
death rate is 7.8 meaning over the
course of a year
you would expect 7.8 deaths per 100
people of per thousand people for all
different causes now if we use that rate
we would estimate that over a
three-month period you would expect
between five and six deaths per hundred
people these are rough numbers so if
you've got a group of 40 000 people you
would expect to see about 235 of them
die over a three-month period this is
aside from testing anything but that's
just an estimate and the other thing
that's important to consider is that
that number that I gave you 7.8
that's not just adults that's everybody
that includes younger people the death
rate for 18 plus again aside from
testing a vaccine would be higher than
the death rate for the entire population
because the risk of death increases with
age and when you do only 18 plus you
would have a higher expected death rate
than for people of all ages all the way
down to newborn so it's an estimate the
number of people you would expect to die
in a group of forty thousand would vary
but the point of it is the fact that
people died in the three months after
getting a vaccine doesn't actually tell
us anything people die and a group of 40
000 people will die so then we get to
this particular died suddenly conspiracy
theory here they want to talk about
young people are dying healthy young
people are dying now first of all when
we say healthy in many cases we don't
actually know the full history and what
we mean by healthy can vary in a lot of
different ways so that is fallacious and
lacks evidence at the top of the of the
discussion but here's the real really
important thing the crude death rate for
those aged 18 to 34 is about 3.3 deaths
per thousand people per year that's just
the average crude death rate in the
United States the CDC believes about 65
percent of those aged 18 to 24 got a
full regimen of the covet vaccine that
means the two initial doses forget about
boosters that's not part of the data but
65 percent of those 18 to 24 got the two
doses that means if we have about 32
million people aged 18 to 24. 65 percent
of them are vaccinated meaning 21
million people aged 18 to 24 received
the full dose of vaccines if you look at
that crude death rate
and you look at the number of people who
have gotten vaccinated you would expect
70
000 deaths among that group over the
course of a year now you will have
endless circumstances you will have
motor vehicle accidents you will have uh
cardiac episodes you will have cancer
you will have all you will have covid-19
in some of you will have all those
different things the fact that some
people aged 18 to 24 died
in the period after which they got a
vaccine tells you nothing five stories
ten stories 20 stories about a 21 year
old who died seven months after getting
a vaccine
and we don't exactly know the
circumstances or we vaguely know but
it's a privacy issue it doesn't tell us
anything about the safety of vaccines
and what is missing from this analysis
in most cases is this issue of the base
rates what are the base rates of death
in all of these different categories
it's basic stats it's basic research
methods and its basic common sense and
logic and that is not a surprise then
that it is completely missing from the
minds and the discussions of these
conspiracy theorists so don't fall for
it don't fall for it understand these
Concepts causation correlation base
rates critical stuff
when Republicans start to control things
politics gets very stupid in the United
States that's something we are very
quickly learning and we have a new
Scandal is that even the right word a
scandal involving classified documents
in Joe Biden when he was vice president
let me tell you what's going on and then
let me tell you what these right-wing
clowns are saying CNN reports classified
documents from Joe Biden's time as vice
president discovered in a private office
what exactly happened here's a CNN
report explaining it these were
documents uh the White House says that
were found by the former pres by the
current president's attorneys in
November as they were closing out an
office that the uh the the former Vice
President Biden of course had set up an
office with the University of
Pennsylvania at the Penn Biden Center
here in Washington and they were closing
out these offices when they found what
they say were fewer than a dozen
documents that were labeled as
classified now a number of these
documents were also subject to the
president Financial records act and
according to the White House these were
now turned over to the National Archives
which has asked the justice department
to look into it now right we're told uh
now Jake that the that the Attorney
General Merritt Garland has asked the
U.S attorney in Chicago to conduct a
review of these document
documents uh which is a standard process
that they would go through this is a
Akin to the process that happened after
the National Archives asked the justice
department to look into these classified
materials that were recovered from
Mar-A-Lago from the former president
Trump's residence so it is a process
that the justice department recently
went through obviously with Donald Trump
of course the difference here is that
according to the White House it was the
the president's uh legal team that
reached out to Nara to turn over these
documents as opposed to with Trump who
fought for months and months not to
turnover documents that the archive said
needed to be turned over Jay so that's
one critical difference but there are
actually a number of other critical
differences misplacing and stealing
documents are not in fact the same thing
now investigate everything investigate
this I don't know anyone on the left
who's saying don't investigate but
misplacing and stealing documents are
dramatically different things it doesn't
matter to a lot of these right Wingers
who are immediately saying things like
for example what Marjorie Taylor green
said last night on Fox News propaganda
this Tucker Carlson's program
well this is a huge story it's very
serious as a matter of fact Joe Biden
conceivably stole those documents
conceivably is doing some heavy lifting
in that statement what people need to
understand is the president of the
United States is the only one that can
declassify documents not the vice
president for Joe Biden to steal
documents and have possession of them
a serious investigation and the
Communists that Nera can't hide it
anymore there's no Communists at narrow
Garland and the Department of Justice
they have to be held account accountable
if they don't treat Joe Biden exactly
the same way they're treating president
Trump yeah they should be treated the
same way in that the facts should be
evaluated by law enforcement now it's
really important to understand this
story these documents were in a locked
closet
Joe Biden's attorneys found them
immediately contacted the National
Archives remember with trump it was
throw all this crap in a box take it to
my house at Mar-A-Lago here you had
documents that were misplaced and as
soon as they were found rather than
trying to hide and keep the documents
Biden's lawyers proactively reach out to
the National Archives
dramatic difference from what we saw
with Trump and then they were handed
over to the archives the next day
as opposed to fighting for months lying
and claiming that you turned them over
you didn't being caught on tape moving
them between locations while still not
turning them over
barely comparable
I'm consistent investigated it's being
investigated I love that let's
investigate this and hey you know what
if Joe Biden's house needs to have a
search warrant served as a result go
ahead and do it I'm not getting in the
way uh but of course we know that the
circumstances are completely different
now it doesn't matter to them to people
like Marjorie Taylor green to whoever it
doesn't matter they want to say hey this
is the exact same thing Trump did and
he's being treated differently actually
he's being treated the same it's being
investigated it's the circumstances that
are completely different I hope you're
all buckled in for two years of this
because this is what the next two years
are going to be like and it'll be Hunter
Biden maybe they'll go back to Hillary
and Benghazi they might investigate
Obama's tan suit it's going to be that
sort of stuff and when Marjorie Taylor
Greene is shifting into being seen as a
sort of de facto spokesperson for the
center of power of the Republican party
you know it's going to get really stupid
tomorrow 6 PM Eastern is the next David
pakman show Town Hall I hope you will
join me we will be streaming live I will
be taking questions and comments from
everybody in the audience we will give
priority to our website members and you
can sign up at joinpakman.com in order
to get instant access to the bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money yeah everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad and you
will get Priority Access to talking to
me during the town hall thank your lucky
stars every day you're not Dave Pacman
well you some people want to talk to me
Alex okay and we'll be talking to some
other them tomorrow we'll take a quick
break and be back right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is of course made
possible by people like you people who
listen to the podcast or watch the
YouTube channel and sign up at
joinpakman.com I would love for you to
sign up on the website you'll get
instant access to the bonus show you get
access to a commercial free audio and
video stream of the show every day hours
before anybody else gets the show and so
many other great member benefits we will
also soon be announcing a member-only
town hall uh probably in the next few
weeks stay tuned for that you can sign
up at joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get a discount the
Donald Trump indictment watch has
started as the Georgia grand jury is
done this is a really big deal and quite
literally any day a Donald Trump
indictment could be coming or maybe not
at all we just don't know the Associated
Press reports Georgia grand jury ends
probe of trump and 2020 election this
special grand jury in Atlanta
that has been investigating whether then
president Donald Trump and his allies
committed any crimes while trying to
overturn his 2020 loss in Georgia has
finished its work bringing the case
closer to possible criminal charges
against Trump and others uh further down
the decision whether to seek an
indictment from a regular grand jury
will be up to Fulton County district
attorney fani Willis I thought it was
Fanny someone told me it's funny I hope
I'm getting it right will a spokesperson
Jeff DeSantis said the office has no
comment on the completion of the panel's
work McBurney wrote in his order the
special grand jury recommended its
report be made public he scheduled a
hearing for January 24 to determine
whether all or part of the report should
be released and said the District
Attorney's office and news outlets would
be given an opportunity to make
arguments at that hearing since June
there have been dozens of witnesses and
on and on and on in conjunction last
month the house committee investigating
the January 6 2021 Insurrection asserted
in its final report that Trump
criminally engaged in a multi-part
conspiracy to overturn the lawful
results of the 2020 presidential
election and failed to act to stop his
supporters from attacking the capital
the report concluded that investigation
as well
this is a possible uh fork in the road
it's not really a fork it's actually a
coming together whatever the opposite of
a fork is of the Georgia investigation
and the house investigation and we could
see no charges we could see charges in
Georgia but not federally federally and
not from Georgia or we could see charges
from both and it will be absolutely
wacky if we see any of those
combinations that involve charges CNBC
also reports Georgia grand jury probing
Trump for 2020 election crimes possible
2020 election crimes completes work
Trump also faces a federal criminal
investigation into his attempt to
overturn the 2020 election which he lost
one interesting note
um from this article
is where is that interesting note
um Willis in January 2022 asked the
chief judge of Fulton County to consider
her request for impaneling a special
purpose grand jury to invest investigate
potential criminal interference in 2020
a majority of the judges in the county
approve the request okay so that's the
critical line not every judge so even
even as to whether this grand jury
should have been impaneled there was not
a unanimous uh decision from the judges
that made that decision and we should
expect that similarly there will be
dramatically different perspectives on
this at whatever the next step is and it
is
um we can't definitively say that that's
a result of disagreements that are
partisan in nature but remember this
idea that judges merely take the law and
the facts and put them together in
outcomes one and only one answer we
regularly see disagreements and with
something as part partisan and
politically oriented is this
we all know there's going to be a
partisanship involved now if Donald
Trump is indicted it would create all
sorts of Chaos in the American political
landscape number one he's a current
candidate for the presidential
nomination for his party and the first
question is what would be the
implications and the consequences for
his campaign for Donald Trump to be
criminally indicted would he have have
to step down and what does it mean that
he would have to would he have to
legally what do you have to because of
uh public opinion of what what would
that do to the Republican ticket what
would it do to Ron desantis's chances or
would it further open the door for
someone other than Trump and DeSantis we
just don't know but it would be very
chaotic secondly
public reaction
we have said many times before that
Trump is basically right when he says I
could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue and
not lose any support or at least he was
right in 2016. maybe that was also true
in 2020 is that also going to be true in
2024 not totally clear to me at the same
time there are certainly followers of
trump who will see the indictment as a
political attack or at least as a
politically motivated attack it might
engage them further it might unite in
some way Republicans in favor of Donald
Trump I just don't know it's
unpredictable
um and then finally what would an
indictment of trump mean for the future
of the country
and what I mean by that is there is this
I tradition convention it feels weird to
use that term but there is a precedent
and a tradition
of the doj
not
indicting sitting or former presidents
and we have not seen criminal charges
against a former president and so what
would the impact of that be on the
country in the future if such an
indictment were to take place so it
would be chaos it would be chaos
politically it would be chaos legally
and it could be chaos constitutionally
and it may all happen within a few weeks
or not at all or not at all I am still
not convinced that charges are coming
although I believe they are obviously
warranted and I know most of you feel
the same way Tucker Carlson is defending
rioters in Brazil and baselessly
claiming that the Brazilian election was
quote rigged I don't think this will
come as a shock to many of you Fox News
propagandist Tucker Carlson
who has taken very strange positions on
Russia's invasion of Ukraine who has
taken very strange positions on
everything from free speech to terrorism
over the years you know he says flat out
the election in Brazil was rigged and
then he uses that to justify and defend
the rioting that we are seeing in the
Trump riots Brazil version that we
talked about yesterday let's listen
thanks to what was very clearly a rigged
election a convicted criminal called
Lula de Silva is now the president of
the most important country in South
America
millions of people in Brazil understand
exactly what happened they know that
their democracy has been hijacked
possibly forever
but there's not much they can do about
that Lulu may be a criminal in fact he
is but he has the full support of both
the bid Administration and the Chinese
government well he won
that's an important detail he won
so yesterday in frustration a group of
Brazilian protesters swarmed their
legislature watch thanks to what was
very so then then he shows the video
um Tucker Carlson then goes on to say
that what happened in Brazil is being
likened to January 6 but that that is
very much not the case let's take a
listen to this you may actually have
seen some of that video in the United
States over the last couple of days and
you saw it because it has political uses
what's happened in Brazil is being
likened to January 6th and of course
populist leaders in this country are
being blamed for it oh it was Trump and
Steve Bannon who did it that's not true
but even if it were true it would be
just the tail end of the story it would
be the result of something that happened
before
so the obvious question is why are
protesters in Brazil so angry right well
they're angry because the new Lula
government has eliminated their most
basic civil liberties Lula is working to
turn Brazil into a chinese-style
dictatorship and he's doing it very
quickly with maximum aggression what and
our media don't want to talk about that
because it's not true refuse to why well
for reasons that should make you very
nervous yeah listen I'm it's it's
incredible when the right becomes so
extreme and unhinged that I end up doing
the strangest things on the show and
what I mean by that is I'm no fan of
Lula politically in the sense that of
course if I was in Brazil and my choices
were Lula and bolsonaro I vote Lula but
I've told you Lula is in the mold of
this sort of
populist rhetoric kinda corrupt uh in in
the vein of some other South American
leaders where he's better than bolsonaro
but it's not like I go wow this is
someone I really really think is a
absolutely fantastic person but if I'm
on the side of the rule of law there is
no option here but to defend the legal
basis for Lula's win period to defend
the legal basis for Lula being the
president and to unanimously and and
categorically condemn what is happening
in Brazil and a similar attempt to what
we saw in the United States because at
the end of the day Tucker says well it's
different
it's different in that the mass arrests
of the rioters seem to have started more
quickly that's that's good
it's different in that it's happening
after the inauguration rather than
before that that's true it's different
in that the guy they're rioting on the
behalf of bolsonaro is in Orlando in a
hospital after going to KFC in a Publix
that's different okay than what Trump
was up to on on the day of the Trump
riots but it is the same in the sense
that people are destroying property and
being violent and trying to overwhelm
police because they want a candidate
that lost to be the president that's the
exact same thing Brazil counted all of
its votes in hours just the way Maga
wants the United States to do they did
it in Brazil but still they say it was
fraudulent Brazil's military found no
fraud in the election and then they say
well they but they didn't rule out the
fraud well what exactly do you mean by
that they didn't rule it but they didn't
find any oh no no they but that that's
that's weird language uh it is indeed
the same thing in terms of its
motivations and at this point
should we even be surprised that we are
seeing Tucker defend the rioters I say
no we'll have these clips on our
Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David Pacman
show and please make sure you are
subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with Dr Eli
Merritt who's a political historian at
Vanderbilt University and also editor of
the recently released collection of
essays the curse of dimagogs Lessons
Learned From the presidency of Donald J
Trump it's really great to have you on I
appreciate your time
thanks good to be here David so I I
think just one place to start would be
one of the big discussions that's now
happening in the aftermath of the Trump
presidency and you know we're still
waiting to know whether there will be
criminal charges or not and that may be
part of this conversation
did we learn that the checks and
balances and safeguards put in place by
the founders were not strong enough if
we had a president interested and
willing to do the things Trump did or or
is that too bold a statement to make
right now
well I think we learned that lesson in
something else uh the the checks and
balances that were put in place by the
founders uh back over 200 years ago as
you know with the Electoral College and
the powers of impeachment and conviction
and disbarment from future office yes
for very long the electoral college has
not worked and so the real truth is soon
after uh the the Constitutional
Convention 1787 ratification 1788
political parties became the dominant
instruments of our politics and also
they became the dominant instrument of
checks and balances against demagogues
and authoritarians making it to the
presidency so I I many things I believe
failed in the Years 2015 until
continuing today but the most
significant failure of checks and
balance is the most significant failure
of Gatekeepers against demagogues who
become authoritarians is clearly the
political parties our political parties
are woefully weak today and we can talk
more about sort of the origins of that
but they became relatively emasculated
starting in the early 1970s when all
checks and balances at the nominating
conventions were removed let's talk a
little bit more about that you know I I
have not found anyone who disagrees with
me that Donald Trump could not have won
a Democratic primary now the reasons why
people might disagree with my reason is
a little bit crude which is even though
I'm neither a republican nor a Democrat
I don't believe Democrats would have
fallen for what Trump was offering
whereas the Republican electorate by
definition did fall for it in that
they've made him the nominee in 2016. uh
is that a fair is that one of the
differences right now between the
parties in terms of the constituents and
then are the differences between the
constituents greater than the
differences between the party structures
I would say it seems very clear right
now at this point in our history that
the Democratic party is the party of the
Constitutional rule of law it is the
party of ethical leadership no party's
perfect and no and no and and the
entirety of the political uh figures
politicians in any party are not ethical
um but I think it's a hard question to
ask Democrats would never elect Trump
but I I think the most important thing
to clarify here
is that we have descended somewhat into
what I like to refer to as a demagogic
culture
and I I would not ever remove the
possibility that as the culture and the
politics become more and more Fierce and
some a liberal-leaning demagogue might
come along who has similar Tendencies
and angers and frustrations and a
personality as Fierce as Trump's
and if we get into this black and white
thinking if we think the other side is
evil I do believe Democrats are also
susceptible to uh demagogues that's why
what we do in one party is something we
should do in other parties and again I
think the most important area of
intervention the most flexible point of
intervention is the uh presidential
nominating system a lot of people don't
know that very little law governs
certainly not the Constitution governs
political parties and the nominating
conventions right so it's just a matter
of the party's deciding to make changes
and they could do some inter-party
compacts to use to to guarantee that
each of them will and veto the emergence
of individuals who clearly do not
support the Constitution will not
solemnly swear to uphold free and fair
elections in the peaceful transfer of
power and other things when we talk
about today I think the Democratic party
feels quite safe I really do I agree
with you there but it would feel like
hubris to predict over the next 10 or 15
or 20 years if we don't clean some
things up that they could become
susceptible to demagogues oh I agree I
all of my assessments are as of today
and you know when when we hear people
say when Trump would say at the State of
the Union the U.S will never be a
socialist country it's sort of like
never is a long time you know maybe not
I don't think next year there's not too
many socialists right now in positions
of power but I think never that we want
to be careful with never if we go back
to 2016 a little bit there's a lot of
blame that is often placed for how Trump
how no everybody failed to stop Trump
and sometimes it's you know James Comey
doing that extra press conference to
talk about Hillary's emails that was
totally unnecessary that was the
Difference Maker because it was so close
or the media giving free publicity to
Trump is what allowed him to keep
accreting two three four percent every
time another primary candidate dropped
out that was the reason or
Democrats selecting a poor candidate in
Hillary Clinton is what's to blame now
when it's so close it's very hard to say
one thing is to blame because any one of
those things could make a difference but
given that
how do we assess the lack of ability to
have stopped Trump in 2016.
I I think that responsibility goes
around everywhere to our basic education
system to the structure of our news
media as you're saying and uh you know
events like James comey's relief release
of the emails or his judgment about that
are very significant but I would again
posit that
the only Surefire direction to go is for
political parties to block the emergence
of demagogues and authoritarians
entirely from entering the general
election if I'm not mistaken all of your
questions related to the general
election and so there are certainly
there are reforms that can help to
prevent a demagogue authoritarium within
the uh general election from succeeding
but they become for their base you know
religious figures and addictive figures
so the most important thing that can be
done
if there were two things I would
recommend it would be first and foremost
that the political parties do their job
and return to the party having the power
and the platform having the power and
the candidate having to adjust to the
platform which I think should begin in
both parties to have statements that
surround the Constitution and the oath
of office for example the other thing
where we woefully failed
is is in the process of impeachment
conviction and disbarment from future
office
the fact that after January 6 after four
to five years of witnessing Trump's uh
bigoted speech and damage to our to our
nation that 43 Senators voted not to
convict him either shows they do not
understand democracy they do not
understand demagogues they do not
understand that democracies can fail or
that they succumbed to the cowardice
pathway of hyper partisanship so I think
both play the roles of those are the two
most important places for intervention
we could make an effort to at least
educate our politicians to understand
these phenomena better you know the
interesting thing about that is what you
describe is what many Bernie Sanders
supporters
say happened in the 2020 primary and
they don't like it and what I mean by
that is there is a story that's told and
there's degrees of truth to all of these
things of course that despite the people
wanting Bernie
the party coordinated
uh I'm now searching into my memory but
it was I believe Pete bootage and a
couple other people getting out at the
perfect time to get Biden South Carolina
with which he built momentum to
eventually become the nominee we all
know the story and a lot of people are
angry because they say now the people
should have the power even if Bernie
whether Bernie was destined to win or
lose in a general election it should be
the people not the party that gets to
decide you're saying something quite
different which is actually the party
needs to be the Safeguard
I'm saying something completely
different I do I believe powerfully in
representative government
and representative government has always
focused representative government with
layers of democracy and layers of checks
and balance this is always survived and
functioned better than pure direct
democracies so yes what I would actually
like to see happen in the reform I I
think would solve or get close to
solving the problem of demagogues
getting into the White House would be to
let the parties pick the presidential
nominees and let the people pick the
president that is in fact the way it was
done for approximately 190 years in our
country and we switched that in the
early 1970s and I think we're living the
consequences of making that switch so I
would have the people be very involved
in voting the people would vote for the
delegates
and hopefully by ranked Choice voting
that may be something you've covered on
your program indeed indeed and then the
delegates would go the stepwise fashion
to the way it used to be done is County
Convention State conventions and the
national conventions I think today they
would just go straight to the National
Convention and there they do their work
just like the elect uh delegates to the
House of Representatives in this country
we elect them to go up there and do work
which is to study the situation and make
determinations so the first thing these
elected delegates would do is establish
the party platform and then they would
determine which of the candidates who
are involved actually will fulfill the
mission of the party platform and not
take over the party the way Trump has
done most most countries in the world
and variations do something like I've
just described very few countries have
direct primaries and I I do believe they
will continue to be uh arrows in our
sides and possibly fatal to our
democracy meaning we will become a sham
democracy not meaning we're going to
engage in Ultimate Civil War but it's a
sad thing for me to think will be a sham
democracy we're only a democracy and
name and otherwise corrupt officials are
are engineering everything behind the
scenes to look forward a little bit I'm
curious about your assessment of what is
currently happening within the
Republican Party in the sense that we
have these very unusual circumstances in
which this demagogue Trump made a very
early announcement that he's running in
2024 he has barely left his home since
making the announcement it's unclear
really what the case is that he's going
to make for his next nomination a guy
who hasn't announced anything Ron
DeSantis is actually leading Trump in
some polling the speakership Fiasco from
the last week has exposed it's no longer
just Pro and anti-trump even within the
Trump side you've seen this division
Marjory Taylor green and Lauren bobert
on opposing sides of that division is
something fundamentally changing here
um do you I want to ask you to say more
about that James what something changing
in the Republican party for the better
or worse is that what you're alluding to
well better or worse is more of a value
judgment but is the dynamic of it's the
people for and against Trump and it's
that simple is that Dynamic changing
where you're actually getting even more
fracturing where the Maga side is now
dividing
well I I think what what what Trump has
done is he has opened the mainstream of
the Republican party and the nation to
some extent to what Nelson Rockefeller
called back in the 1960s this is his
quotation The Lunatic Fringe so I think
it's hard to predict though 20 um
Republicans who or so who were opposing
Uh Kevin McCarthy yeah I just think
evidence a lot of qualities in general
that are very destructive to
representative government it is
grandstanding it is not thinking of the
best interest of the nation it's a
little bit of this Lunatic Fringe coming
in
so where things go I am not certain I I
do know that we continue to have within
the Republican Party the the forces of
Mitt Romney who have been somewhat
profoundly weakened I should say yeah so
I don't know where the future of it is
my real hope would be
that at some point that there will be a
conservative party that splits off from
this Republican party and that the
American people decide that this way of
living through uh demagoguery and lies
and and fear-mongering and hate
mongering is not something they wanted
that we did that experiment now we want
to move on from it that's my hope so but
I do think Ron DeSantis uh clearly their
their criticisms of him he he's not a
demagogue if you just look at him speak
you'll determine the man is does not
have the rhetorical talents and
destructive abilities of of trump some
people worry he could become somewhat
authoritarian
but I've looked carefully at what he's
done in Florida and there's some
questions there yeah to my evaluation
this answers appears for the
Constitution to be a much safer bet than
Donald Trump and Donald Trump I think is
something's happening for him I think
he's becoming somewhat deflated uh by
what's happening and so hopefully he
will he he could implode and and and
become more dangerous to our democracy
as we have seen with his comments about
the Constitution yeah but it's all quite
unpredictable as I'm sure you agree when
we look in history what sort of events
have catalyzed realignments in parties
were parties significantly shift
uh I think it what what one discovers
I'm thinking of the beginning of the
Republican Party in the 1850s when you
asked that there is a sense that there
is a national crisis that the uh that
someone needs to address and the Whig
party for example at that time yeah was
determined not to be willing to go in
the direction that the Republican Party
wanted at that time and it was clearly
not an anti-slavery platform but it was
an anti-expansion of slavery platform so
a critical mass had been met there
or they felt this sickness has gone on
in our nation long enough
and we cannot get Traction in these
other parties and critically
back then there was more flexibility in
the system certainly there was not this
entrenched uh money in politics and the
political industrial complex that makes
it so hard to form third parties now
that's a bit of a challenge and it's
very worrisome that third parties can be
wonderful things and again you know the
Republican party was a third party that
yeah that rapidly grew and did well so I
think it's crisis and so it could be
that the current crisis of demagoguery
and authoritarianism and Corruption that
we're beginning to witness now that
could in the hands of Eliz Cheney for
example
become a catalyst for starting a third
party and I think it should be done even
if predictions are it can't succeed we
need to see people do the right thing
and make efforts in spite of the fact
that there's concern that we are a
hopeless two-party system yeah I could
not could not agree with you more on
that um the collection of essays
recently released is the curse of
demagogues Lessons Learned From the
presidency of Donald J Trump we've been
speaking with the editor uh Dr Eli
Merritt from Vanderbilt University
really appreciate your time today thank
you so much
great to be with you David
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
the failed former president Donald J
Trump is now suggesting that Republicans
work to wreck the economy for the next
two years because that would be good for
Trump in 2024. if you could imagine a
more depraved
anti-American idea to benefit oneself
politically than this I quite frankly
can't think of it I mean if if you put a
gun to my head which many of these
people would gladly do I guess the worst
scenario would be
allow or even encourage a terrorist
attack in order to place me as the
person in charge to unite the country
after the attack to increase my approval
rating that it if you say to me can you
think of something worse than let's
wreck the economy uh it would probably
be that let's take a look at what Donald
Trump posted to his platform truth
social yesterday
very very there's a serious lack of
Truth here posted in all capital letters
as Donald Trump uh often does
saying quote Republicans can get almost
everything back that the old broken Crow
Mitch McConnell and the real leader
china-centric Coco Chao he by the way
he's he's referring to Mitch McConnell's
wife Elaine Chao that is his sort of
racist xenophobic nickname for her
stupidly gave up to the Democrats over
the last two years by simply playing
tough in the upcoming debt ceiling
negotiations Trump is saying don't
negotiate allow the government to
completely shut down allow basic systems
to fail which will wreck the economy and
then that'll help Republicans in 2024.
that's what Trump is saying you have to
read between the lines here and it's
pretty easy to figure figure out what
he's saying with the right negotiators
like all of those involved the other
night on both sides for speaker
it will be a beautiful and joyous thing
for the people of our country to watch
make America great again Trump thinks
the American people would enjoy watching
basic Services go unfunded due to
political maneuvering because it would
be
good TV I mean
the depravity here is one level but
actually I want to put that aside for a
moment put aside for a moment the
immorality the depravity the lack of
ethics of this idea of ruin the economy
so that then Trump can swoop in in 24
and say look you need to be back and
I'll fix all of this right away put it
aside for a second
I actually believe it's bad political
strategy the long-term consequences of a
damaged economy I believe outweigh the
short-term political gain it takes a
long time and a huge amount of resources
to recover from an act of deliberately
screwing up the economy for two years
and forget about would it be irreparable
let's concede it's reparable but you
could be talking about years quite
frankly
if you were to say let's unite and let's
not do the debt ceiling if and when it
comes to be necessary if we need
stimulus because of some crisis let's
not do it if we need funding for a
natural disaster let's not do it on and
on and on and on right
I actually believe that the damage you
do will reach far beyond the two-year
term that you think would basically be
compartmentalized nicely to help you in
2024 because deliberately wrecking the
American economy in order to win future
elections
of course it's unethical of course it
lacks Integrity of course it's a total
abandonment of the principles their
principles give me a break it's an
abandonment of the principles they claim
to to to uh value and of course it harms
Society in the short run but it's bad in
the long run and as a result it's also
not a good idea for the political for
the Republican party now Trump views a
wrecked economy as a key to his election
in 2024. he expects that Kevin McCarthy
is going to honor some kind of
commitment to wreck the economy to Trump
that would be insane if it is the case
and they need to be held accountable if
they do that now let's be honest if if
we if nothing else I'm honest with all
of you
if we are honest even when Republicans
don't say it or don't realize it
their actions have been disastrous for
the economy for decades now
that's just the reality trickle-down
economics where you cut taxes for the
rich to
raise the tide for all boats it doesn't
work
flat out doesn't work we've had
economists on we've looked at the data
just doesn't work and so Republicans
would never say we're going to cut taxes
on the rich to wreck the economy no they
they might even think it helps the
economy but it doesn't so the policy has
been bad for the economy for a very long
time
um Reagan exploded uh spending while
cutting taxes it's been policy for a
very long time Bush started two Wars
created the Department of Homeland
Security and TSA while giving tax cuts
to the rich
come on it's the same thing Trump added
trillions in debt while giving tax cuts
to the rich this has been what they've
done for decades but now Trump is just
openly saying let's screw it up let's
screw it up and then Americans will
figure out how much they want
Republicans in 2024. it's absolutely
disgusting almost as disgusting
as the very ugly war between Lauren
bobert and Marjorie Taylor green let's
talk about that next we have now for
several weeks been covering we could
call it a rupture we could call it a
crack a crevasse maybe between radical
republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green and radical republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert or bobert as
rokana likes to call her The Divide is
deepening take a look at this
unhinged is the word that Lauren bobert
is now using to describe Marjorie Taylor
Greene there is a good Associated Press
article bobert's backers urge her to
tone down the nasty rhetoric but when
you do a search for unhinged you see
uh bobert saying the following I have
been asked to explain Marjorie Taylor
Green's beliefs on Jewish space lasers
or why she showed up to a white
supremacist conference I'm just not
going to go there bobert said over the
phone as she wrote in a car winding
through the high Canyons near her
hometown of silt before the speakership
vote she wants to say all these things
and seem unhinged on Twitter so be it so
be it so then we hear from Marjorie
Taylor green and Marjorie Taylor green
says that Lauren bobert's approach to
selecting a speaker isn't serious take a
listen I think the American people no
matter how you vote are sick and tired
of drama and this is nothing but drama
we're we're on multiple days now with
multiple candidates from this group so
I'm not sure how Lauren bobert on one
hand can demand so much out of Kevin
McCarthy and then demand nothing out of
someone else and be willing to vote for
them to be speaker that's not serious
um I don't think that's leadership and I
really see it as more obstruction than
progress yeah this is absolutely
fascinating you know I know that many
many people sadly even in my audience
are using the sort of misogynistic term
cat fight to describe this oh it's a cat
fight uh whoa uh this is actually a
really interesting political Rift and
I'm going to tell you why
before this Rift the Republican Party
had Maga and they had non-maga they had
the pro-trump Republican party and the
anti-trump Republican party so you had
very very sort of neatly defined for the
most part on one side uh Mitt Romney
Adam kinzinger Liz Cheney the anti-trump
people and then you had Maga and Lauren
bobert was part of Maga and Marjorie
Taylor green was part of Mecca what you
are seeing now is an intra Maga Civil
War you still have Mitt Romney right and
Mitt Romney is not part of this bobert
thing and Mitt Romney is not part of
this Marjory Taylor green thing now he's
also in the Senate so he doesn't vote
for the speaker and in that sense he's
also separate but now you see a
subsequent division happening within
Maga and what's going on is that there
are basically two bets that you can make
and Marjorie Taylor green is making one
bet and Lauren bobert is making a
different bet and it could be
entertaining in the short run but very
consequential in the long term for what
happens with the Trump movement and
whether there is a trump movement going
forward Marjorie Taylor green
who was you know Q Anon follower
promoting violence Jewish space lasers
all this different stuff
she has started to reorient herself as a
voice of reason within the Republican
party she is presumably going to get
committee assignments back with um uh
Kevin McCarthy as Speaker of the House
she she is now becoming part of the
establishment Maga side she's still a
trump supporter but she's probably
realizing that Trump's power is
diminishing to some degree
she wants to transform herself
politically she's making the BET of I'm
gonna ease up a little bit on Maga I
support Trump but I'm part of this other
contingent
Lauren bobert on the other hand is going
full in with we are the defectors we
know what's really good for the country
these people like green and others they
might say they support the ultra Maga
Wing but when it came down to it they
acquiesced or maybe even they gleefully
went over to feeling like we're now in
power we are now the the the big the big
boys and girls or whatever you want to
say
one of the really great things about
bobert targeting green is it's going to
pull green back into the mud so she
can't wipe herself off and say I'm with
McCarthy now you know I'm uh you know in
the in the mafia you might say I'm now a
made man you know I'm in a different
category at this point he's a friend of
ours rather than just a friend of mine
you know if you've read books about uh
the mafia some of those terms make sense
Marge wanted to sort of be the rat
fleeing the the sinking ship after the
Trump riots failed on January 6th and
the Red Wave failed to materialize and
then Republicans argued with these 20 or
so of them uh resisting and resisting
she saw the opportunity to flee the
sinking ship but bobert is trying to
pull her back in and it's all good for
the left in the sense that the more
fractured this movement is I believe the
better it is for the Democratic party if
you disagree with me let me know we have
a voicemail number which is 2192 David P
you can call anytime here's a caller who
has a very specific question for me
David my boy
what would it take you to go to a NASCAR
race okay I have never been to a NASCAR
race I don't really care about NASCAR I
don't find it interesting but I don't
have any real opposition to going I
don't know if there are NASCAR races in
like the Northeast I'm just not sure
maybe up north like in Upstate New York
it's the type of I know Upstate New York
is is pretty conservative and Rural
maybe up there or not even Upstate like
Western New York Northwestern New York
maybe there I would go to a NASCAR race
it wouldn't really be for the racing the
racing seems quite boring but it would
be more as a socio-cultural I would go
as an anthropologist I think is what I'm
saying all right so if someone wants to
take me uh maybe we'll we'll document it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we're going to talk about the
rules package passed by Republicans
we're going to talk about what's going
on with IRS funding and Republicans and
we will talk about how Q Anon is
responding to the Brazil riots and more
when producer Pat joins me sign up at
join dot com get instant access it's a
great thing